thank you
[Music]
all right this one is a crazy story
crazy good but uh so many people have
messaged asking us to talk about it
because I think you guys will enjoy
hearing it
it's about a girl named Janice this
happened in the Philippines danis yeah
Filipino Japanese
it's already so correct so it's a it's
gonna be sad I need a cookie it is gonna
be sad take all the cookies okay the
butter cookies too
so this is in 2013.
there's a girl named Janice she's eight
years old they randomly find her on a
ship all alone
and she claims that she doesn't have any
memory of anything prior to that day how
old is she eight eight this is like life
of pie Filipino style yeah kinda yeah so
they find her and they the Wim the woman
who finds her like posts her picture
this is like the first picture of her
when they found her she was they just
found her literally like at a is that a
purse what is that like a he has a
little bag yeah but she didn't have
anything on her that could identify uh
where she was from but all she knew was
that her name was Janice sebial
um Janice yeah that's got to be like
main city-ish right to not have like a
more like tagalog-based name like she
has like a westernized name I guess I
don't know if that's Western I don't
know what it is it's like an office
worker's name yeah I know a couple
januses the whole the complete thing
sounds like a it's not a real name yeah
so they just they immediately just uh
you know they're characterized her as an
orphan and there are a lot of those in
the Philippines
um I hate orphans eventually
because the department of social welfare
doesn't have like a family to put her in
they uh they found a couple that would
hire her as a live-in nanny
so she's the nanny yeah she like helps
out around the house man she needs a
nanny I know yeah
so uh what happened I think it's their
culture guy so it's all good oh yeah I
don't wanna be prejudiced or anything
like that Hospitality yeah so they hire
as a nanny and then
so she does that for years right fast
forward she's now 17 years old and she
works for this family still and
sometimes the family brings her to like
little events here and there and uh she
met another girl there at the event
uh that girl's name was Gwen and Janice
and Gwen became like best friends they
would do like tick tocks together here
they are doing one that's Janice and
Gwen right there doing some little
tickets which one's Janice the smaller
one okay the one in the back the
malnourishable oh the one that works all
day doesn't eat the one who was found on
a ship yeah so um the one with the thick
calluses so Gwen Gwen comes from a very
like nice
got a brother named
Luke um they're all kind of a similar
age
uh Gwen starts to beg her parents to
please adopt Janice because she goes
Janice while she does work she doesn't
have any hope for like a a real future
because that that'll happen to you in
the Philippines if you start working as
a nanny at a young age you'll probably
do that your whole life yeah probably
die doing that at like 80 or something
so um join the Navy or [__] yeah
nurse or something yeah yeah that's the
goal right dancer yeah all right so they
beg the parents to adopt Giannis which
they actually end up doing that's cool
yeah so they adopted Janice
um and now they all live together and
everything and oh here's a picture of
her story let's [__] go thank you
guys for the video that's it right
that's it I don't want to hear those sad
[__] man I'm good so what do you guys
want to talk about in the post-credits
scene Janice ends up um
so they're assuming that like there's
kind of gonna be a little bit of a
complex where if you people get taken in
start to develop a fear of losing the
thing that they have no no no no no no
no at one point she she stole 200 from
them and
um they ended up finding out she
confessed it and revealed that uh she
like sewed like a pocket in her backpack
to hide it and she said she was sorry
she doesn't know why she did it
um and they just assumed or she must
have some like trauma issues from you
know being abandoned that's really
mature of them they didn't just cut her
hand off or some [__] that's really cool
yeah
did she have this issue when she was a
maid or like a nanny or whatever doesn't
say that she had any other time that she
had done that so she wants to go back to
being a nanny maybe I mean is for her
she must have seen the other family as
family too she's been with them since
eight she's definitely very grateful to
be in this family she likes that she's
not a nanny she's like I have way less
chores yeah that's that's definitely you
feed me it's definitely established that
she she likes this battle in buckets it
was great so she um and this family's
really really loving um not so nice
they're also very religious so you know
they're always like trying to figure out
like yeah and they treat her like blood
she's like a blood family relative to
them
um and then something weird happens see
this is why people think I'm Shady but I
say never bring Strays back
so uh Janice on her Facebook and this is
odd because this is this is a very
significant date for them uh December 10
uh the parents made breakfast for the
kids they left for work
um and then Janice posts something on
Facebook that says it was a Manifesto
it's roughly translated to help me some
people broke in I'm hiding under the bed
and it's like she's currently uh hiding
from these these people that are that
broke into the house
um so then a colleague sees that post
and tells the dad so the dad's like oh
[__] he rushes home
and then he sees the other two kids
stabbed to death
uh the girl had 21 stab wounds and the
the boy had 51.
and did they go like well this is
obviously some kind of past trauma
so we can so let's see if there's any
other sewn Pockets or anything like that
or any other kind of productive way we
can look at this yeah but Janice was
magically alive and she goes hey at
least you still have me she covered in
blood she does come out not covered in
blood but covered in water and they
think it's really uh obviously it's
weird she says that um I took a shot of
my clothes I fell in the pool yeah I
fell in a puddle took a shower cried all
over my clothes she said that she she
wanted to bathe after basically her
story is that someone came in and
attacked them and then after when she
was hiding she decided to take a bath
because she felt like you know to like
calm herself down she just had to do
that movie sometimes yeah we do a lot of
this attack here
I mean what if the reason why the bloody
nose was the doctor after James Bond
killed that African dude threw him out
the window he's sitting in the shower
and
she had a bloody nose and she's on her
period that's why the drain has blood
around it not because of anything else
movies and I'm like this girl burned her
whole family down and she was alone in
the boat and then she goes I don't know
what happened yeah that's her that's her
story is that somebody came in and
attacked them the bodies they're
surrounded by bloodied up pots and pans
a hammer a baseball bat whole room
covered in blood
um and I bet you the dad's [__] he's
like so mad that he didn't install that
Google home that he bought yeah because
I bought those cameras and I [__]
never sitting right there it has a ring
but he didn't pay for the live yep yeah
because you and then you got to replay
yeah it's just for show so a lot of the
uh they end up having investigators look
over the whole crime scene there's a lot
of stuff that doesn't really match with
her story oh yeah namely the timeline
like she posted those
um those statuses on Facebook after the
murder technically happened based on the
autopsy
and also um they they didn't understand
why she was why she took a bath first of
all yeah that was crazy they then find
uh and why didn't she call the cops
immediately yeah there's a lot of things
wrong with that they end up finding us
like an ID card of some other dude like
a 17 year old guy in Janice's bedroom
and um
they don't know who he is they asked
around the town and the people around
the town were like yeah that's the guy
that was asking directions how to get to
the house
and then one witness even said oh yeah I
gave that guy a ride to this house
so he she might have manipulated a guy
or actually is a guy that just came in
randomly did it so there was a guy that
did do it and then they find a plastic
bag and a creek next to the house
um that bag had a bunch of stuff in it
somebody tried to throw it in the creek
to like Let It wash away but it caught a
branch and it was just stuck that's how
it goes total luck yeah inside of it was
uh a bunch of Blood Stained clothing it
matches the blood from the scene and
also a baseball bat uh that was used to
kill the boy and on it were Janice's
fingerprints oh and then when um when
they confronted her about it then she
immediately broke down and said that she
orchestrated the entire murder with a
boy that worked at the church uh that 17
year old guy and um his Alias they're
using is Marlin and basically they
planned the murder 10 days prior to uh
to kill both of the kids because Janice
was so jealous that the girl was getting
all this attention from the mom that she
just wanted to take her out and then she
never said well she'd just be Maids
until they die
she never said why she even killed the
brother
um why didn't she do it to the other
family that's so weird she stabbed him
like a lot of times that family she was
working for the other so they treated
her like a stupid so if you bring me in
she's like super [__] up to you yeah
she's like you love her and then
she really was like I don't want to lose
this thing and I don't want them to have
it I want it all like exactly yours this
is why you can't be too nice bro no you
can't that's right you can't I told you
guys you don't bring [__] Strays in
dude I was drunk I was wrong the saddest
thing is that uh so they when when she
was going over the details of what
actually happened oh God it sucks so bad
so they learned that um originally
so the guy comes in and starts attacking
the brother the daughter the sister Gwen
actually managed to get away and she got
out of the house but she came back to
Rescue them oh but what about calling
the police
or neighbors and she said that uh Janice
admitted that while she was stabbing
Gwen the girl that the girl said she was
saying this is just a dream this is just
a dream I'm still gonna be a doctor I
don't know what wrong I did to you
Janice I love you very much that was her
last word oh but she's not capable of
love you stupid idiot
the Strays aren't there's too much
travel it's crazy she met the other
killer at church yeah he worked at a
church yeah the [__] I know what's that
guy's deal he was like yeah I'm down to
kill a whole family I'm a Christian
killer yeah you know he was just a crazy
sib I think she's a full-on sociopath
and a mastermind and they can manipulate
the [__] out of people that brings us to
the very final twist she was never an
orphan to begin with oh my God the
entire time oh my God I got chills at
that point she was communicating with
her mom since eight years old yeah so
she's been a psychopath as a child who's
the mom R Kelly oh I don't know
hey host the show [__] yeah yeah do
your job and check if it's R Kelly it
says crazy no it's not him it's just
it's the person who who performed
Ignition Remix oh
[__] eight years old she's been a
[__] professional bullshitter
oh my God
that's what I'm saying is what was the
end game for the Randy's [__] crazy
so the thing is she's she's kind of from
like a deadbeat family like she's from
like these two parents who are like
totally bad and um basically that's so
scary they don't really know the full
story but I guess the Dad ran out on him
it was just the mom
um and they don't know if she ran away
or if she got kicked out actually the
mom ran out and then the dad stayed but
they don't know if the dad kicked her
out or if she just left but she was just
by herself and uh the crazy thing is the
mom of the kids who were murdered ended
up contacting Janice's True Mother
and they met up and that true mother
apologized to uh the mother of the kids
and and she for Dave for this because
they're Christian because they're
Christian yeah and because
my new religion is not forgiving and and
the crazy thing is they were hoping to
forgive actual Janice herself but when
they finally saw her again at the
courtroom they said that her eyes were
just so cold and empty and she showed no
remorse guilt or ever apologize
sociopath they just couldn't yeah
couldn't do it
uh but they did uh forgive the mom for
because the mom was also very sorry that
she even I gave birth to these monsters
give the mom a knife have the mom kill
Janice and then the mom kills herself
yeah it's the only way it's fair tickets
that sounds pretty fair to hashtag JK's
Justice on social media yeah thank you
God dude yeah this is a picture of the
brother and sister that passed away
that's Gwen and Lewis oh my God so sad
man he was he was he opened her home to
this [__] chick dude yeah dude yeah
someone they thought was an orphan
I wish people had better
um [__] radars because like a long
game and that's Kid to Kid yeah that's
like it's the kid that was like the kid
crazy this trick is either she was
raised by R Kelly like for all we know
she you know she's she's stabbing this
[__] chick and she's like my mind's
telling me
we don't know
the mother and father that uh that this
happened to they opened a restaurant in
the memory of Glenn and Lewis and they
served their favorite dishes that they
like throwing off oh it's not that Thai
restaurant right this is where the story
is
and it's that Thai restaurant that's the
real ending of it that's yeah what's
that thing is they open a restaurant man
put up a zoo
kids dude for real that's what I'm
saying dude dude imagine ordering at
this place and the person's strong on
this did you order at this place and the
person brings it was like oh yeah my
daughter would love to eat this video
the one that was brutally murdered [__]
this is her favorite spaghetti this was
yeah oh [__] banana spaghetti I think I
was a little bit like I wouldn't want to
I mean I would want to support but then
like it feels sort of spooky maybe it's
our culture that that feels spooky maybe
bro this little story is [__] smooth
because every time you eat there it's
something It's a Spooky ass [__] it's a
grieving experience a dining experience
yeah that's like all the things that she
used to like maybe it's that's you know
people got weird ways to coach yeah yeah
isn't that just the craziest saddest
story ever
yo what's up there all right so the
moral of stories do not adopt no Strays
I mean I was I was no [__] strains
dude shop do not adopt adopting I was
like let's say we like get like
semi-retired and we have a pretty good
life I don't know tyco's like taika's
like 18 going to college I'm like I was
talking to Jim like would you be down to
the doctor said a lot of kids that need
homes and stuff you know and I'm like
that might that might be cool you're so
nice we did pretty good for us there's
so many horror movies about it but then
I hear [__] like this [__] tiger
comes home for Thanksgiving he gets
stabbed the [__] up nope I'm out I will
adopt any of your guys's kids because I
know where the source is from it's like
okay okay so like you're Godfather yeah
what's their favorite foods like they're
they're young right it was their
favorite foods just dino nuggets
[Music]